qu'est-ce qu'il fait ici
nous avons trouvé votre fille elle est
vivante préparez-vous aux changements nous avons un
thérapeute pour enfants avec qui elle travaillera
quatre ans c'est long ce dont elle a besoin en
ce moment c'est sa famille monsieur
chéri
c'est maman
bienvenue à la maison esther nous sommes partis  c'est
comme c'était
c'est agréable d'être de retour ma famille me manque
beaucoup
notre objectif ici est d'aider esther à se
réacclimater à la vie au sein de l'
unité familiale
ton temps d'absence
comment est-ce possible il y a quatre ans, elle
dessinait encore des figures de
bâton le comportement d'esther a été si erratique
bonjour maman
merci maman
j'ai remarqué
certaines incohérences qui m'atteignaient
c'était comme une performance
si tu n'es pas esther qui sont  toi
[Musique]
j'en ai besoin pour toi
[Applaudissements]
la mère protège sa famille
peu importe
c'est le pourquoi de t'aimer